So I'm here to talk about
enterprise level data
science success.
It's making data scientist
success in a large company.
That's what I want
to talk to you about.
Who am I?
I've used R for about six years.
I come from an
engineering background.
In my professional role, I
lead a data science, analytics
and software team in the
supply chain organization.
The silver lining of
the last two years
is I don't have to explain
what supply chain means
to anybody, from toilet
paper to semiconductor chips.
Everybody understand
what supply chain means.
Flex is a large electronics
manufacturing company.
It's a Fortune 500 company.
It's located in 30
different countries.
We manufacture
electronics things
in 30 different countries.
Outside of work,
my primary role is a
dad to two young kids,
and mom currently thinks I'm on
vacation in a fancy conference
resort.
The session was themed,
working with people is hard.
It is hard.
I agree that it is
not easy, but I'm here
to try and convince you a
little bit that it need not
be this hard.
So what does data science
success in an enterprise mean?
I'm going to give
you one definition.
That's my definition.
When there is effort that
leads to some output.
And then there
are decisions made
with that output and actions
and outcome for an organization
or an enterprise.
So we know what the effort, the
tools that we use in the effort
and the outputs are
we use R and Python.
We publish our outputs.
Now for the second part.
Decisions are generally made
with other people in meetings,
whether it be with
higher ups or your peers
or with people who will, who
are the practitioners and users
of the output that we provide.
And actions and
outcomes typically
mean we make more sales,
we make more revenue.
The key performance
indicators show improvement
after implementing
the analytics.
My talk is going to
be centered around
the third and fourth phases of
making data science success.
And in most organizations,
data science and analytics
is a means to an end.
It is.
Success is measured by
dollars and metrics of what
is important to the business.
So it's a means to
an end in most cases.
I see four sets as very
fundamental to data
science success in a corporation.
It's the data set, the
toolset, and the skill set
is talked about a lot
in this conference.
We have different
tools that we have.
We improve our
skills. In this talk,
I'm going to talk
more on the mindset
within an organization of how
to take it from development
deployment, where the first
two boxes that you saw
implementation
actioning and outcome
is what the mindset change that
is required for the last two
processes.
Partnership. This is a
word that means a lot.
And I emphasize this
within the organization.
There is a tendency to
treat data science and IT
organizations as
a service provider
within an organization.
My passionate recommendation
is to not settle for this.
Ask for equal.
Ask to be equal partners.
And what that means
is the data science
team gets equal input
to key decisions that
are made with the analysis
that they get to offer opinion,
they get to guide the non
datas and the business people
to execute on the output.
And in return, the
data science team
also owns the business outcome.
So we take on an
additional challenge
of owning business outcomes
and not just model deployment.
So in terms of maturity
of an organization
to utilize and
implement data science,
I think of these
as two dimensional.
One is the analytics maturity
or data science maturity.
This could be
ingesting large amounts
of data running complex models.
The other important vector
is decision maturity.
Is the organization.
How good is the data
literacy of the organization?
How good are they
in decision making
with the uncertain
outputs that we have?
Both of these vectors will
have to grow for data science
to be successful
in an organization,
and they have to go
grow simultaneously
and both have to mature
for it to be a success.
Decision maturity
is a fancy term
for saying have a decision
framework to utilize the output
that is given from analytics.
And for the data
science team, it
is important to understand
what are the key metrics that
are important for the
practitioner of the analytics
or what's important
for the business?
And we talk a lot about model
metrics, model accuracy,
classification error,
whatever the case might be.
The model metrics only need
to beat the current business
process metric to
be implementable.
It's a two horse race.
Model accuracy does
not need to be at 99%
to be implemented if the
business process metric is
today at 70%. You don't
have to beat the world
record to beat the other horse.
You just have to
beat the other horse
and then make decisions to
implement the data science
side of things on the
business side of things.
This is contradictory
to, you know,
working nicely with people.
It's important to
pick some fights
and you have to fight
for the right reasons.
Friction is a very necessary
component to moving forward.
Good friction is good.
That removes hurdles
and blockades
that sometimes come when
different teams have
to work together to
move things forward.
I want to make an
illustration or an example
of how do we go from model
output to decision making?
You see a picture of Google
Maps that takes us from where
we are today to Dulles Airport.
Many of us will be making this
trip in the next 24 hours.
Google Maps tells me it's
going to take 45 minutes.
I ask the question
to Google Maps,
how long is it going to take?
But that's not
the real question.
When I have to make a decision
with the answer it's given me,
the decision making breaks
down into multiple tree type
decision making.
Do I want to take Uber
or can I afford to
take public transportation?
Do I have time for coffee?
When you put this
decision making framework
on top of the very
complex analytics that's
running behind Google
Maps, that gives you
a framework to connect
data science to business
type decision making.
Talk to your stakeholders
to understand,
what decisions do
they really want
to make with the data output?
Going from a generic
example, I'll go to a
supply chain and
a specific example.
Within the supply
chain organization,
we have analytics
that support, that
provide output for what the
price of a part should be.
My organization and company buy
millions of parts every year.
So the current, you can see
the scale of the pricing.
When we provide most
of model outputs
that show lower
than current price,
the person who has to execute
on it when they first see it,
they get some pressure.
They get some pressure
or fear that they have
to go meet that target.
And that pressure or fear is not
within that one person's scope,
but their manager
also sees this data.
So that's where the
pressure comes from.
So there is a very high
chance that giving analytics
in an organization can
create some pressure or fear.
However, if the person
were to achieve any lower
price for that part,
whether it meets that,
regardless of whether it
meets the target or not,
that's an opportunity.
So you it is very important
to work within an organization
to change people's
perception of analytics
from feeling pressure or fear
to creating that opportunity
and growth mindset.
So we call it the pressure
to opportunity mindset change
and it takes time when you
work with different teams.
And humans tend to judge
machines and models very
harshly.
I'll give two scenarios with
this exact case of pricing
a part.
Now let's take the case
of the part was the dollar
and the model output was $0.90
and the actual achievement
after the negotiation was $0.95.
In in case one or scenario
one with the model,
people tend to judge
the model and say
the model has 50% error.
In case number two
or scenario two
without a machine or a model.
And when a human went in with
a low bid as a starting point.
And they started with $0.90 and
got up to $0.95 as the result,
it was a good
negotiating strategy.
So humans tend to judge machines
and models in a very harsh way.
We have a lot of empathy
towards other humans.
So what we have learned
in doing analytics
at scale within a
large company is
be aware of being judged
in a very harsh way
and prepare for that.
So with people, there's
building relationships
with relationships with
people up, down and sideways.
Up the management
chain, with chain with
your teams and your peers.
The data science and analytics
team to be successful,
have to learn to understand
and talk the language
of the business teams.
When we say models and
random forest and regression.
Everybody does not
understand those terms.
It makes them a little
closed and feared.
So we have to open up and
learn to talk their language
to get how they can
execute and do their jobs
better with what
we are giving them.
And building a
successful team takes
time. Manage, lead, and coach are
three different
things and all three
have to be done in
a different way.
And similarly, as we
challenge the non datas
to speak our language, we have
to challenge the data science
team in an organization to
speak the business team's
language.
Some pitfalls that
I've learned over time.
When management asks for
machine learning, whenever
they start a question
is, let's see if
AI/ML can help here.
That's usually a rabbit hole.
Can we find something
interesting from the data?
That's another big rabbit hole.
Be aware of scope creep
in an organization.
Have a clear plan
and a threshold
for aborting a project with
your project stakeholders.
So working with people
need not be this hard.
Working with people is a
very necessary component
of enterprise
level data success.
So thank you.